monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse aux ministres de l'économie et
j'y associe mon collègue rachit et mal
depuis l'an dernier l'inflation n'en
finit plus de ne plus finir les prix des
produits alimentaires ont grimpé de 14,5
% en un an et une nouvelle hausse de 10%
est à prévoir ces deux prochains mois ce
chiffre est en effet le plus élevé
depuis
1985 face à cela quelles réponses vous
apportez aux Français vous demandez aux
enseignes de pratiquer pendant trois
mois je cite les prix les plus bas
possible sur un ensemble de produits
leur choix je suis sceptique quant à la
crédibilité accordée à ce genre de
déclaration qui traduisent plus un vœu
pieux que l'institution d'une mesure
concrète cette volonté de rien imposer
au distributeur est incompréhensible car
de la veut même de la BCE une grande
partie de l'inflation serait tirée par
la volonté des entreprises de
sauvegarder leurs marges afin de
maintenir leur profit
le candidat Macron nous parlait de
mettre en place pour les ménages les
plus modestes un chèque alimentaire ma
question est donc simple quels
engagement comptez-vous prendre devant
la représentation nationale afin de
donner un cap lisible éclair pour nos
concitoyens un cap qui ne soit pas
l'otage de vos revirements incessants et
vos renoncements permanents un cap que
vous devez à nos concitoyens tant la
situation est difficile pour les plus
précaires d'entre eux
pour vous répondre la parole dans la
ministre déléguée en charge des petites
et moyennes entreprises
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Sénateur que zig vous parlez de
revirement qu'elle revirement
quel revirement quand depuis octobre
le président de la République Jean
Castex à l'époque puis Elisabeth borne
engage 110 milliards d'euros pour
soutenir les factures d'électricité de
nos concitoyens pas un pays européen n'a
autant soutenu le pouvoir d'achat mais
si on peut être en désaccord sur
beaucoup de choses mais pas l'être su
110 milliards d'euros c'est pas de la
flûte monsieur je vous réponds il y a au
moins le respect de m'écouter ce serait
sympathique 110 milliards d'euros ça se
vérifie 46 milliards 46 milliards jus
sur l'année 2023 pour accompagner les
factures d'énergie
alors excuse-moi et j'ai encore la
liberté de regarder où je veux oui merci
non suivez je vous remercie donc ce
gouvernement n'a jamais eu de revirement
en matière de soutien au pouvoir d'achat
vous le savez très bien et le soutien il
est massif et d'ailleurs vous l'avez
voté ici au côté des Français ensuite
vous critiquez avec force le trimestre
anti-inflation que nous avons mis en
place avec la grande distribution c'est
la première fois et vous le savez pour
connaître ces sujets monsieur le
sénateur cosyke la grande distribution
de façon unanime s'engage sur trois mois
vous savez très bien qu'en général les
promotions c'est deux à 15 jours de
promotion troisième engagement au delà
d'être engagement rapide et collectif
cet engagement il est juste ils prennent
sur leur marge pour assurer que les prix
n'augmentent pas avec Bruno Le Maire
nous avons donc beaucoup travaillé avec
eux durant trois mois ce trimestre
anti-inflation propose des centaines de
produits à nos compatriotes la direction
générale de la répression des fraudes et
de la concurrence surveille d'ailleurs
aux côtés des distributeurs que les
marges sont bien prises les efforts sont
bien faits sur les marges des dis
tributeurs et nous avons appelé avec
Bruno Le Maire à ce que il y est
possiblement une nouvelle négociation
pour faire baisser les prix s'il
continue à baisser le prix des matières
premières au printemps au mois de mai
avec les industriels alors aucun
revirement de la volonté de la
détermination et une inflation qui au
globale demeure l'une des plus faibles
d'Europe je vous remercie monsieur kozic
madame la ministre les Français ont
besoin de stabilité chaque alimentaire
abandonné panier anti-inflation
abandonnés à la fin je crains que ce
soit les Français qui soient abandonnés
avec vos dispositifs montés comme une
usine à gaz c'est 50 nuances de prix
dans un panier percé avec l'abandon du
panier inflation vous placez le pays
dans les mains de la grande distribution
dont les marges ne faiblissent pas tout
en faisant passer ces dernières comme
les principaux acteurs de la lutte
contre la vie chère la République en
marche se mue en la République en marge
si à la fin ce n'était pas le
consommateur qui payait tous vos
revirements